miss france qui êtes vous
tout a commencé à quinéville ce soir là
c'était le début d'une grande aventure
aventure qui allait se transformer en
apothéose au 31 décembre au casino
d'enghien miss normandie une jeune et
jolie fermière de 19 ans devenait miss
france pour elle la vie allait changer
le monde
les cadeaux les grands couturiers mais
malgré ce bouleversement la vie à la
ferme est toujours la même la famille
beck est avant tout une famille unie
pour eux miss france c'est toujours
nanet
j'aimais françois ce matin aux halles
est triste c'est les deux groupes
d'inventer ce matin oui et d'éléments de
les démarrer ce matin avant de les
dévoiler très heureusement terme avec
colère parce que je te jure qu'il y
avait la demande
eelv intérêts des intérêts de retard
at-on bien fait de m'appeler va se
passer lorsque tu es particulière à son
compte un jeu parquet cinq heures tu
arrives à 5h30 et déjà des 50 voitures
c'est le bonheur n'est pas dire powder
la literie de jeudi au nom j'ai oublié
le passé et téléphoné parce que si les
basques ont atteint bettman
de longs cheveux d'or
des yeux de la couleur de la mer qui est
là tout près à la pointe du rac
jeune homme et la mer et on jette dessus
de la mer aussi un petit peu et après
vous êtes né ici si vous aviez été un
homme me vous aimez la mer
mais on on passe pas là je prends pas
mais j'aime bien la mère parce que j'ai
pas le temps que je passe du bon temps
mais c'est ce que j'aime bien selon la
garde et j'aime bien aimé remet en
talent et en bateau
visible mais souvent bien entendu
souvent passé à caen chez les huit mois
plus tard avez vous l'intention de
rester cultivatrice ou
mais ça dépendra le mariage c'est une
attention vous marier bientôt à quel âge
ne sait pas aujourd'hui vous êtes le
célèbre os a dû transformer totalement
votre vie bien sûr si vous aviez un juge
et miss france quelle qualité exigeants
riello d'ailleurs qu'est ce que vous
pensez si vous n'étiez pas miss france
qu'est ce que vous demanderiez à miss
france qu'est ce que je pourrais
demander qu'elle soit belle bien sûr oui
et encore vous qu'ils soient plus simple
offre ne sais pas parmi toutes les
questions qu'on vous pose
il y en a une qui revient souvent on dit
m est ce que vous êtes une vraie
cultivatrice est ce vrai que vous créiez
des vaches mais oui c'est vrai et puis
vous fait des tas de travaux de ferrer
oui on fait tout ce qu'on peut faire la
ferme c'est ce qu'on a mis fin tôt les
trois mots que je préfère me soit mes
parents besoin de moi alors que ce soit
à l'extérieur ou faire le ménage
tu sais ce qu'est ce point il ya des
gens qui s'étonnent que on ait trouvé
miss france avec une triste soit une
fermière
ça ne vous irrite pas un petit peu ça ne
non ça ne mérite pas d'en face c'est un
peu surprenant quand même comme on est
en difficulté à comprendre que le
fermière puis cette miss france un peu
surprenant parce que dans le fond rien
d'extraordinaire ville à la campagne
donc vous aimez les bêtes certainement
oui oui j'aime bien aujourd'hui une
souffrance
vous êtes combler êtes célèbre pour
semer des cadeaux avait beaucoup
d'admirateurs
on vous a demandé en mariage déjà mais
aussi la bienvenue et non au mariage
zingraff vous on vous propose des
situations si certainement non pleurer
elle intéresse à la mairie et vous faire
du cinéma ne pense pas que voudriez vous
faire cesser de choses je ne sais pas
non plus vous n'avez pas pensé à ça j'ai
jamais pensé à ça j'avais jamais eu
l'occasion d'y penser
alors je ne sais pas je revienne en vtc
ou demain on me demandait qu'est ce que
vous voulez faire
je voudrais je trouvais très bien comme
ça oui
qu'est ce qui vous manque qu'est ce que
vous voudriez avoir encore chaud car oui
j'étais paraissait déjà beaucoup ce que
j'aurais demandé à vendre ce serait de
pouvoir voyager un peu ça me donnait
donc pour l'instant demande rien vous
avez pris l'avion
c'est la première fois vous prenez la
veille c'était la première fois quelle
impression ça vous a donné je peux on a
l'impression je crois que c'est le
cinéma ou la télévision on al'impression
déjà bien d'avoir été j'ai eu
l'impression de qui et jaguar est un
avion ça me paraissait tout normal en
faillite
j'étais quand même pas dire vous allez
au pérou vous avez reçu un accueil
certainement très chaleureuse à papa oui
fort du talent ce thème était très très
bien
on a parlé aussi au pérou évidemment
c'était un canular du journaliste on a
parlé de fiançailles non mais c'était le
garde du corps il était toujours avec
moi et interprète pour ce que les
premiers jours les trois premiers jours
on avait un professeur de maths
conserver la teinte et retraite et
les restes du temps par la dizaine de
jours c'est lui qui servait d'interprète
donc pour tous aux admirateurs n'êtes
pas fiancés jeanne drecq pour vous où
est le vrai bonheur des formulaires je
crois que meneur de jeu contentait de ce
qu'on a maintenant qu'on vit avec des
gens qu'on aime
puis de lévis salle je crois
miss france
avant tout
une grande fille toute simple